is jungle cruises is it related to the
ride it is basically
right okay my kids are going to freak
out they love that's their one thing
they always want to do
it's uh it's a it's a it's a great movie
i'm very proud of it
it's funny and it's uh is that i mean it
reminds me of
those great movies we grew up to you
know like indiana jones
i was gonna say indiana these big
adventurous movies yeah
i love the junior move the chair that
was like my favorite line that's my sean
connery you're welcome
um so so what is the movie about though
so i get it that it's about the rye but
it's something yeah i mean we're
like a lot of different people with
different intentions get to
the jungle to try to get something
for different reasons okay so it's a
little like tomb raider yeah exactly so
we're gonna get something
um i mean i this is a spoiler you know
spoiler territory yeah spoiler so we're
all there to get something
out of the jungle for different some of
you have good intentions some of you had
better
exactly yeah okay i'm a little bit of
both okay so open meeting
you're like good and naughty at the same
time oh my god it's your theme
in life yep i'm still here just waiting
for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever